التوترات الاخيره في كوسوفو تعيد تسليط
الضوء على قوات النيتو الموجوده في ذلك
البلد الاوروبي الغالبيه المسلمه
قبل ايام اصيب عشرات من قوات النيتو في
كوسوفو والمعروفه باسم كيف فور خلال
مواجهات مع مواطنين من العرقيه الصربيه
شمال البلاد الذين تدعمهم بالجراد اثارت
صور مصابي قوات كي 4 حفيظه دول الناتو
التي سرعان ما قررت ارسال 700 مقاتل
لتعزيز وجود الحلف الساعي لحفظ الامن في
البلاد ساهمت في التعزيزات الجديده قوات
تركيه تقدر بخمس مئه من الكوماندوز طارت
نحو كوسوفو ونشرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
صورا لها مساهمه استدعت امتنانا وشكرا من
النيتو لتركيا خلال زياره امين عام الحلف
لاسطنبول انا
ارحب بقرار تركيا ارسال جنود اضافيين لدعم
القوات الدوليه في كوسوفو وسنرسل الان نحو
700 جندي من الحلف وتركيا ستقود الجهود
الدوليه لارسال هذه القوات كي فور او
قوتكسوفو ارسلها النيتو الى هناك صيفه عام
استنادا لقرار مجلس الامن
1244 وذلك بعيدا انتهاء حمله الحلف الجويه
ضد النظام
والتي استمرت 78 يوما دفاعا عن رغبه البان
كوسوفو المسلمين في الاستقلال عن صربيا
وريثه نيوزلافيا السابقه التي تفككت قبلها
بسنوات في البدايه تالفت قوات النيتو
بيكوسوفو من 50 الف جندي اخذت في التناقص
بناء على تراجع التوتر في البلاد وانتشار
الامن حتى بلغت حاليا نحو اربعه الاف
مقاتل وفق الموقع الرسمي لقوات النيتو في
كوسوفو فان مهمتها تهدف اصلا الى ردع تجدد
الاعمال العدائيه وتهيئه بيئه امنه وضمان
السلامه العامه والنظام وتجريد ما يسمى
بجيش تحرير كوسوفو من السلاح ودعم الجهد
الانساني الدولي والتنسيق مع الوجود
المدني الدولي تندلع الموجه الاخيره من
التوتر في كوسوفو على واقع استقطاب عسكري
دولي حاد ينخرط فيه الناتو بفعل تداعيات
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
دعواته اليوم في كوسوفو تجد نفسها في
مواجهه خصم شديد التماهي مع موسكو لدرجه
اقدام عناصر من صرب كوسوفو خلال
الاشتباكات الاخيره على رسم حرف z على
مركبات النيتو في اشاره للشعار الروسي
خلال حرب اوكرانيا
موقفا رافضا لاستقلال كوسوفو المعلن عام
2008 ونقل قبل ايام عن سيرجي لافراف وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ان الصربه في شمال كوسوفو
يقاتلون من اجل حقوقهم محذرا في نفس
السياق مما وصفه بانفجار كبير يلوح في قلب
اوروبا
[موسيقى]